this is a production of cornell
university
thank you so with that i i i
last time indeed i discussed more the
public private social sector
collaboration also in another seminar uh
we discussed um
scenarios for the 2025
uh
plus uh kovit kovitt world and today i
actually tried to bring a bit together
thinking
at symmet related to agriculture of
focused climate change but especially
because i want uh to invite uh cornell
and and the school uh to to discuss with
me but also with symmet scientists can
we push the envelope of what agriculture
can actually do
for climate change what can how can
agriculture play a role to become the
solution and how can we reduce it as
being a problem so what i'm trying to do
with the the seminar today is probably
provoke a little bit of uh showing you
where we are at symmet but i i would
like
you t to to
if if you allow to give me later on the
gift and and simmet the gift of saying
okay what what what do you think what
can we do together to really push this
more aggressively and and
and and way more push the envelope of
climate change in the nexus
of agriculture
so hopefully we can have that
conversation uh in the in the
future live encounter
so uh to get started obviously what we
will be talking about is the nexus
between climate change and food uh
productions production sorry
agricultural systems are extremely
sensitive to climate change in the one
end extreme weather uh higher
temperature uh they are highly dependent
on stable long-term conditions that
determine productivity quality of the
output
and yields
a lot of what we have been doing as
agricultural researches is driving
efficiency
and i think today we need to ask the
question if we should not take a more
systemic look at the whole agricultural
enterprise or the nexus between
agriculture and climate change that not
only looks at efficiency but it actually
looks at systems performance which
includes resilience
and obviously also certain degrees of
efficiency
unefficient resilience is probably not
that difficult or unefficient uh
uneffective efficiency is also not that
difficult we need resilience
effectiveness and
probably a certain degree of efficiency
where's the balance i don't have the
response farmers struggle actually today
to cope with increasing climate risks
that affect food production and also
their capacity to at the same time their
demand that they're asked for there's
pressure on our systems to meet the
rising global food demands and obviously
beyond food we probably have to if you
look at a systemic intervention how can
we have healthy
affordable sufficient
diets produced within the climatry
boundaries or within this climate nexus
at the same time we also know that
agriculture does contribute
a substantial amount to the climate
change
impact uh 25 percent of greenhouse gases
come from agriculture activities and if
we look at how that is
divided and you see a couple of
other numbers here but it all depends on
how you how you consider certain
elements but what i wanted to show here
within that contribution of agriculture
and and land use change
what are the elements and if you look
there's a 13 soul fertilization
obviously uh 33 percent comes from
ruminant
production um
a lot of uh apart from manure obviously
also within agriculture energy is an
important is an important factor and
then obviously uh rice
and and rice production especially if it
is um rice production
in flooded
conditions
so the climate change challenge to food
production if i zoom it into
the specialty of cement which is wheat
mace based systems including uh
production of wheat and maize but also
beyond uh we look at what what what is
that pressure and its temperature
increases
obviously reduce global yields of major
crops without adaptation each degree
celsius increase in global main
temperature mean temperature sorry uh
would on average reduce we deal by six
percent and may yield by seven point
four percent and and we see that in our
research site in um
that if we plot yields and night
temperature we see a direct relation
between uh night temperature incredible
critical periods
and
the reduction
of of the yields
on average in the valley unsustainable
intensification to close yield gaps
leads to a loss loss of biodiversity in
landscapes and an increased
pressure on natural diversity and i will
come back because it sits in the middle
also of the debate on land sharing and
land sparing and agriculture needs
biodiversity if we look at the element
of resilience towards the future so
right now where is image focusing as we
speak we are spoken focusing on
extensive research on climate change
adaptation and mitigation in mason
wheat-based production systems across
africa asia and latin america here i
want to do a shout out of a lot of
collaboration with sister centers in the
cgir
system you may have heard from sikhovs
you may have heard which is the climate
change
effort you may have heard certain
seminars on
food security but also in general
security and climate change
climate change focused research aims to
help smaller farmers to adapt to climate
shocks and to raise and maintain yields
profitably in a reduction of greenhouse
gas emissions so this is basically where
we focus today what i would like to do
with this presentation is later on that
you provoke us to maybe think different
or add or or focus on additional
research elements that we should be
together focusing on
and then what what are the outputs of
those research line lines related to
climate change new and high yielding
heat and drought tolerant missing wheat
varieties as many of you know uh 70
of the wheat varieties globally come
from the effort in collaboration with
multiple partners including u.s
universities of course a cornell related
to ug99 rust diseases
come from summit and its network efforts
also maze percent in the developing
countries uh the maze sown in the
developing countries comes from some
it's breeding programs so if we in that
breeding effort standard include heat
and drought tolerance which we have been
working on then of course that would be
a huge impact uh globally on the
adaptation
towards climate change also we look at
conservation agriculture based farming
practices that increase nutrition and
water use efficiency to reduce water
fertilizer and energy consumption a lot
of energy in agriculture goes into
chemical fertilizers
and last but not least we have done a
huge effort
related to monitoring evaluation
accountability and learning systems and
tools that publicly funded researchers
and field technicians throughout our uh
programs in mexico but also latin
america but also africa south asia we
offer them systems to capture those data
in order to then do analytics thinking
that that crowd source that that kind of
citizen science or that kind of farmer
science will help us to get to the
granularity of systems understanding
that we need for interpretations towards
resilience of those systems now if you
look at global impacts if we can do
something with those current activities
to to make them more climate resilient
to to make them more climate adaptive uh
uh
does that actually make sense and yes it
does
generates today benefits between 3.5 to
4 billion dollars annually for mason
wheat uh
for the mason wheat systems
unfortunately this doesn't go back to
summit it is uh well unfortunately of
probably fortunately it it goes back to
the to the system uh to the overall
production um efforts
fifty percent of mesa and wheat in the
developing world is based on cemeteries
sixty percent actually
acreage planted in the united states
uses
cement related wheat varieties and over
80 million farmers are benefiting
through improved mesa and wheat system
farming practices so if we could find a
way to have impact on those elements i
think we could actually have huge
impacts if we want to reduce
climate uh
greenhouse gas emissions we need to do
it at scale to really move
move the needle but also imagine
if we can improve the data that we get
back and i'm now already doing somewhat
of a prospectus the data we get back of
those networks uh what what could we do
uh with all that information so um what
do we want to do more in the future what
is a little bit already future thinking
so increase mason wheat resource uh
efficiency improve crops potential crops
potential to adapt to climate change but
also combine genomic data from the
germplasm bank so we have a biodiversity
bank where we
safeguard 28 000 different main samples
140 000 different wheat entries
so one of the things we've been looking
at is can we map
the genetic variation and then actually
overlay that with where those accessions
where that biodiversity was found in
which conditions
was it found so that we can actually
extract from that potential biodiversity
that has adaptive capabilities for heat
drought and cold stress depending on
where we found naturally that
biodiversity in order then to include
that in our um in our uh
breeding efforts
towards new uh broad adaptable varieties
and one of the new exciting uh endeavors
in this is the use um
of g was or the genome-wide association
studies and here i'm really on thin ice
i am i'm just a simple agronomist so
probably my my colleagues in sumit uh
working with this and and very reputed
uh experts like sarah hern can explain
this this way better but it is about the
genomic predictions uh to identify novel
variations of potential value for
breeding and to predict future
performance of that original of those
land races of the or the original
biodiversity so if we can go back to
those original land races and if we can
project what they would mean 20 to 50
years from now within a climate change
context then actually we can use the
future predictions to do something in
the present which is basically use that
higher genetic value that those that
actually survive better in the world
from 50 years from now can actually
already be incorporated to to get us
prepared through the germplasm
[Music]
it's kind of from the future creating
the varieties of the present uh uh in in
a way
taking advantage of the biodiversity
that's safeguarded and taking advantage
of modern tools
of
genetic
data mining
at the same time can we advance in our
economical practices if we don't have
those better varieties can we increase
research use efficiency to help reduce
greenhouse gas emissions and adapt
agriculture to weather variability and
therefore siemens has extensively
researched and documented the advantages
of conservation agriculture based
practices with average yield gains with
improved soil structure and we will look
a little bit more at that what is
conservation agriculture many of you
know a farming system that promotes zero
tillage minimum soil disturbance
maintenance of soil uh
of soil cover or a permanent or
permanent soil cover or
or a crop cover the end diversification
of the different plant species in the
system
the advantages it has is increased water
infiltration which may lead to higher
yields under drought and at the same
time reduce soil erosion
increased soil organic carbon content
and increased soil microbial biomass and
fauna
as a matter of fact we installed
controlled experiments a network of 20
research platforms and does that
remember my my recent my previous
seminar know that we have a network
throughout mexico of 20 different
research platforms with different
research institutes that follow similar
protocols that are sitting all in
different agri-ecologies so here we are
representing a bit and if you know
mexico a little bit you can go from uh
the the desert all the way uh to the
tropical forest in one country so those
20 research platforms are sitting in a
diversity of um production systems for
for for mason weed we we used three
years data and if we look then at the
soil carbon increases you can see here
on the bottom on the on the horizontal
axis this is the concentration of
organic matter in the conventional
practice if we look at the vertical axis
this is the organic matter concentration
in conservation agriculture if you look
at the zero to five centimeter um
layer uh you can you can see
that in that layer uh
on
overall taking all those 20 platforms
you have a higher carbon content but
even also between the 50 and 30
centimeter uh even even though it is
less less clear so especially an
increased soil organic matter in the
zero to five centimeter layer but there
are also and we need to be aware of that
large variability there is a large
variability among sites so the effects
really need to be validated under local
conditions so at the same time i want to
send a word of caution that it's not
just by increasing uh this that it's not
going to be an easy job to increase
necessarily in all systems uh soil
carbon and that it's necessarily carbon
sequestered it's probably changing the
resilience of the system or say changing
the cycling of the carbon and nitrogen
cycle and and we need to look at it as a
cyclic and as a systemic
element
through sustainable intensification
through those agricultural based systems
we try to decrease the emissions uh
provoked by mason wheat systems and and
avoid the conversion of ecosystems to
agricultural activities this this since
norman borlaug the the the nobel peace
prize winner that is known for saving a
billion lives who started the the the
semit activities we were there were
talks about the warlock paradigm which
is basically seeing if we can produce
more grain per square meter we are
avoiding land use shifts that
agriculture would take over uh
ecosystems or or land uses that are
today's today used for other uses and
that on its own is an environmental uh
service that is obviously the paradigm
of um land land land sparingle and
sharing so that's pairing where you say
if i intensify i spare some of the land
uh and and that has been put as
opposition and and i will discuss it a
little bit more to the land uh sharing
where lynch should be shared in the
activity and as usual in the
agricultural world you will not be
surprised we believe that the response
actually is that the fruit actually sits
in the middle it is a combination of
land sparing in a system that optimizes
land sharing
similar chiefs scaling and sustainable
identification practices and
technologies by implementing what we
call integrated programs
based on compelling theories of change
with multi-actors and i will get a bit
more in detail to that
of course those projects
look at a menu of integration where we
use traditional farmer knowledge
combined with technologies and
innovations to look at agroecological
ecologies and production systems that
can achieve
and preserve nature and protect
biodiversity
while also producing
the food so in the end what we try to do
is a
demand triangulation and trade-off
management in which you have
multi-objective research that no longer
only looks at yield but also looks at
those other uh components that that we
want to uh the the agricultural systems
to to to to
normally produce but to provide uh to us
so looking at despairing and sharing uh
debate it's a heated debate and and it's
more a debate under the conservation er
er ecologists and so we were convinced
with a team from symmet led by um by
frederick baldwin i can go for those
that are interested later on we can we
can go mostly in detail
that we should we had to step as
agronomists into this uh discussion of
land sharing and land sparing where uh
the the yield density relationships that
are classically used by conservation
agriculture is the uh our conservation
ecologist sorry uh is that if you
increase relative view the yield your
your biodiversity density uh would would
go
down uh
and and that that is uh so you have an
overall population maximization with
land sharing that means if you if you
share the land that you can you get the
green curve if you uh do the lens
sparing you get this more purplish curve
between between those between those two
but overall as the yield increases in
both systems the uh basically the
biodiversity would go would go down in
in this model
now what we are saying
is that uh we did a systematic
review in in scopes in november 2020 we
typed in lens pairing and sharing we got
195 articles of which 161 related to
lantern and land sparing really and 65
of them were actually reviews or assays
so more descriptive 96 were empirical
and
or
modeling papers and if you look at the
number of papers that look actually in
this debate at uh at the outcome uh or
or or or really at what it is about so
to say then we can see several had no
indicator was more conceptual and others
only looked at yield as a single
parameter for this debate what we are
saying is that that is not enough in
agricultural performance we should not
look at yield on its own we need to look
at the combination of
crop yield income labor and map that
towards system optimization including
parameters of resilience and including
parameters of biodiversity to which we
are speaking here
and where are we taking this kind of
conceptual elements from it's actually
from the work that we are doing through
our innovation hubs in our food systems
in which we have built that network and
you can see the graph here we have built
up network of research platforms that's
those 20 research platforms that i've
been that i mentioned before with with
the carbon data that are then connected
to what what you can see here on the
screen and i'm actually looking for a
potentiometer i can find something where
i can actually show you on the slides
but i cannot find it right now norris we
we we will do it uh
as we are so you can see those platforms
and then you see something called here
modules modules are actually on farm
trials where you can side by side
compare
farmer practice uh
farmer practices i would i would call
them maybe something that was doing
before and now incorporating into that
new innovations new ideas that we work
out together and from that whatever
works we expand it to into extension
areas and then on top of that we
construct this innovation network those
dots this this weird blobby thing that
is on top of it is is actually the
network that we map of input suppliers
farmers extension servers government
agencies output buyers not amaze buyers
researchers we're all moving into this
knowledge system that is embedded
with this on the ground research and
results and and how does that look like
in the in real life it looks like this
map here
where you can see we have the
red dot is a leader farmer that has a
module that really tests sides by side
and a green dot is a is a is a test site
where farmers apply some of that
knowledge without doing comparisons and
then the blue dot is where uh yet again
other farmers actually apply a second
generation and and no longer are really
testing but just in an application mode
from all those dots we uh
that represent today today those are
plots in the field all those dots
represent 42 000 geo-referenced sites uh
co-development sites from which we get
data streamed back to the data system so
so now with that data we can start
looking at some of those questions um
that i just post uh before
and if we just look at the yield already
we can see that yield is not enough
because let me go from the left side uh
results of that effort an example from
chappas 0.9 tonnes per hectare 3.8 tons
per hectare but more importantly uh two
three point eight tons per acre but more
importantly fifty one five thousand
pesos uh additional income or an example
here from a platform in the central
plateau uh
7.4 tons per hectare in the new uh
innovations that that that were selected
by farmers as most productive
versus the two tones per hectare but but
farmers don't only look at that yield
output
actually we're also measuring what the
impact is on their mace biodiversity of
the practices that we are testing
testing out so what i'm trying to say
here is that high yields may not be the
primary objective of farmers most farms
even in the most remote areas are
connected to markets to some degree and
so there is a link between yield and
profitability although that link is not
always direct
also labor and energy in that sense of
labor productivity may be more important
than land productivity farmers more may
actually uh
care more about the energy required per
ton of crop than the than the tone per
hectare
so many technologies may increase yields
but if they also tend to increase labor
input and therefore energy and therefore
have a very different footprint on
climate change
that may actually uh
give a different preference especially
if we start now looking not only at the
yield efficiency but at the overall
resilience of the system
so extensification for land
appropriation and and speculation is a
driver uh that may as well also drive uh
some of
the farmer of the farmer uh decisions
so we need to look at the same time
beyond the plot if we only look in the
land sharing and inspiring debate or in
this
systems uh debate uh on yield at the
plot as a plot level uh process uh that
would ignore the impact of that same
exercise at higher scales for example
landscape the composition and
configuration could be more important
than the farmer intensity per se because
there's other functions a farmer is
looking at
therefore ecological land use
complementation or how do we complement
land uses and that's more the land
sharing paradigm but at the same time if
you only do blend sharing then maybe
also your output is not working but also
if you have high production and we don't
look at the impact of losses and waste
than the majority of which
the majority of which are occurring on
the farm agriculture and post-harvest
stage in low-income current countries
then again that is a waste of energy and
a reduction in resilience so we also
need to look at mechanization but also
need to look at storage as part of the
overall footprint of our
food production on energy use or on the
climate change impact so in that sense
semitis transforms agri-food systems by
trying to empower farmers to innovate in
their fields and communities by testing
new and traditional methods to make
extension adoption of technologies more
efficient and effective and to integrate
actors in different parts of the
agri-food systems network to work on
climate change mitigation and adaptation
that means yes if we really want to move
the needle it's not only carbon
sequestration but it's also working with
transport or access to market or
food reduction of food waste or storage
etc
where are we doing that in the three
continents and a couple of examples work
in africa and zimbabwe for example
drought tolerant mace uh yielded 600 kg
more per hectare and this translated in
250
dollars per hectare extra income
equivalent to nine months worth of
additional food security at no
additional cost sustainable
intensification practices in that same
area improved smallholder productivity
with 30 percent in malawi drought
tolerant nace a variety is planted under
conservation agriculture so together the
two
interventions a yield at 66 percent more
than non drought tolerant varieties
planted under conventional tillage
practices and farmers therefore
harvested more mace while spending
between 35 and 45 fewer days in the
field if you go to asia in india by
using the happy cedar tractor instead of
the conventional tillage practices
farmers are making 20 more profit and at
the same time we have reductions on
burning but it also
through which they improved the quality
of the air and we are applying less
fertilizer so more than 100 000 farmers
are growing wheat using innovative
machines in bangladesh india and nepal
columbus services uh sciences story at
work in latin america we have dynamic
breeding uh practices going on and we're
developing a national seed sector that
actually can uh
promote a new hybrids and actually this
also helps
with biodiversity in the sense that we
we're injecting new hybrid materials
based on
local seed companies same for wheat 300
000 farmers growing uh rotation of crop
sustainable technology sustainable
intensification on more than one million
hectares in mexico and farmers are
participating in this effort at higher
yields but also higher income
and in the end we try therefore to
encompass the full system and to
actually start
not only how the food is produced but
also processed distributed and consumed
and if we start at the left side with
healthy and affordable diets we move
through this graph to the right side
where consumers are taking decisions on
what they eat so bro we need to look at
right sizing our climate resistant
systems or our climate smart or climate
ready
systems here in the middle that goes
from the use of biodiversity in the
germplasm banks to targeted breeding to
seed systems and input and service
providers smart uh
technologies
um that that supports the carrying
capacity of the earth and the
environment with smart mechanization
integral fertility management aggregate
ecology sustainable aggregate practices
post-harvest
and on-farm decision tools with
bi-directional support and knowledge
generation so that we can sustainable
that we get sustainable and
climate-resilient agri-food systems that
are inclusive that support an inclusive
local development which then goes for
self-consumption
for a farmer that produces but also the
surplus goes through the trade and to
markets is then going to local markets
or to national and regional markets even
global markets to wholesale markets to
agro-industry retail and again back to
the consumer so there is this these two
forces here it is mapping and
visualizing a healthy affordable diet
having it climate uh climate proof uh
produced but then it's also consumer
decision making that needs to improve to
make that work and so underlying of this
whole system is in the traceability and
the sustainability indicator so that we
can actually fuel that decision making
along that value chain that we can make
sure consumers make an informed decision
but also transport is or wholesale
markets or etc have the data to take
that informed decision beyond yield or a
logical output of their economic
activity
therefore we need enabling policies
between rural employment and public
health
supported by research you need
collaborative research and the
development of suitable technologies and
practices the extension systems the food
and trade regulations and the inclusive
growth food and trade regulations just
to take one can actually completely
destroy or can completely support
the the climate readiness of the rest of
the system if they are
the way they're implemented and impact
through partnerships which include
obviously the private private sector and
make sure that we can have scaling our
scaling strategies um effective
but uh having said all of that let's
never forget that we are
at the service in the end and that what
is at the center of our and should be at
the center of our decision taking is
this farmer and his uh or her family uh
working together to produce a healthy
diet for uh the world
and so with that i actually
would would like to conclude the the
seminar not before saying what i now
would like to do is pick your brains on
saying what can we actually do
additionally what can we do better what
can we do differently and can we spark
some collaboration uh in order to climb
make our food systems our healthy diets
climate ready thanks
thank you very much brown uh so
uh that's really fantastic talk so i
like to take a question from the room
first and then uh questions from zul
okay great um
i
i was
struck by your your uh
comment that um which which is close to
where i'm working as well conservation
agriculture uh as
in combination with planned breeding
that you need to actually do both
um uh and and not know breed for
the worst soil or manage the soil or no
improved germ product
so you need to do both and i think the
same applies to to
food quality and nutrition and and
healthy guts uh gut microbiome and so
how do you how do you do that within
your organization and
how do you partner with with uh experts
uh from some earthquake with a very good
talk by roy steiner
earlier this week
who introduced a new initiative of the
rockefeller foundation
and
and that was
not eye-opening
but it really requires this network of
science
and practitioners and industry um that
is it's hard to bring under one roof
um because everybody has their own
incentives so so how do you see the role
of universities in there and how can we
participate and what you are talking
about
uh thanks johannes and i think there's
actually a few elements in what you are
what you are mentioning so so yes i i
i couldn't agree more that it's the
combination of both agronomy and
breeding that needs to that need to work
that need to work together and actually
there's an implicit element in in in
in what we're seeing here which is
actually that we would no longer be
actioning for
masking up problems allow me to say it
like that but kind of say i'm breeding
so the crop still survives
because it's it's it's hammered by by
pests so i make it resistance that's
obviously also important or i'm breeding
for an unhealthy soil so that it can
still get a little bit of nitrogen it's
rather say okay let's let's open it
let's look at it as an integral system
that we want to
to produce certain outputs that are
multi-dimensional so
one part of the question second part of
the question how do you bring
that together in an organization um
i don't have the perfect answer and and
uh
first of all let me acknowledge that
this presentation is actually taking
ideas from scientists all over symmet
and i i just have the honor to to bring
it together in a compelling
integrated element and and at the same
time to develop those integrated
programs call it like that on the ground
where you integrate all those elements
but i actually think that is that is
part of the thinking should be that we
make sure with with integrated efforts
that that start from the outcome so okay
let's let's ask the question what is a
healthy diet for
the highlands of ethiopia
and how can we then design and work that
there's a working system that can
provide that healthy diet for those
living in the highlands of ethiopia and
that's probably a multi
multi-disciplinary multi-dimensional
strategy element and then there's a
tactical element but then there's also a
point where everybody has to go
do what they're good at right so it's
not i don't think it is asking uh the
the deaf breeder or the wheat breeder to
all of a sudden know about about
agronomy it is rather asking that
breeder to take into account uh
information streams uh product profiles
so to look at the profile of this uh of
this new crop that includes
uh elements from social sciences from uh
uh biological sciences uh and from and
from
predictive sciences
and then the third part of your question
is how can the universities work work
together i see i see two elements
the freedom to to push and try out so so
really challenging what i'm presenting
here by saying that there must be
something
more radical more transformational that
we actually can try out and then when we
try it out at the university level then
say okay the next step is okay this now
works as a technology as an innovation
can we actually drop it into this whole
innovation system and see what comes
back can we harvest those data but then
again we would need
the smart the smart scientists and
and and students in the university to
data crunch to data mine to to to those
data that come back from the system
yeah thank you bro
tim uh rob i was really intrigued by
your discussion about land sharing
and land sparring
and
i'm not sure i understand the concept
correctly
but i was i was intrigued with the
possibility that in plan
uh
sharing
it might be possible to take a slight
uh
decrease in the total yield
but
but still maintain very high
bio i guess it's biodiversity
um i wonder if you could just give an
example of what
would be
sure so so the whole and then sharing
and sparing debate is a bit of
conservationist debate where you say
okay if it's land
land sparing is basically say okay we're
going to do this land use here
exclusively i don't know
conservation of
the elephant and we are going to do this
land use here exclusively production of
mace for those living close in the
habitat of the elephant
and we're saying if you do that actually
on the one end that doesn't exist real
land
uh
sparing because probably when you
produce mace and you do it wrongly
something is gonna leak out and still
contaminate the habit of
the elephant even though you have a
fence around
uh the other concept is also is
obviously land sharing let's let's let's
share
the land use
but that then also means what we're
seeing there that doesn't mean you don't
have to optimize still for the
production and you can optimize
production and you can optimize the
function let's say that
the human need function of of a system
uh while still uh respect the other
functions of of that space um we can
have a a more in-depth debate but it is
it's it's a bit of a an example for
example in mexico we have been looking
at um
the same thing in in africa we have been
looking at okay can we set up a milpa
system that yes sacrifice some of the
yield but then has more species output
so it maybe may result in a healthier
diet but at the same time it is
providing more habitat for more diverse
population of uh of different other
species of or different other uh um
animals and and and therefore
can we look at that space on the earth
as what it is providing for the human
functions right which are social
functions which are environmental
functions and food production functions
um
but not shy away from trying to make the
innovations uh not having it as a museum
let's say to to safeguard it on their on
their on their bubble but but still
looking at can we optimize and and
better integrate and still feed we still
need to feed
the the growing population i hope that
response does respond a bit and i will
share that the paper that we wrote on
this method
okay
you're probably guys now
so i'm curious how simmet is interfacing
with
large multinationals
particularly
consumer-facing food and beverage
companies that have
pretty ambitious carbon targets
um even their own regenerative
agriculture programs which some very
similar to
its conservation agriculture programs
um so yeah i just i'm eager to hear more
of how how
sumit is interfacing and how those
partnerships with the private sector be
facilitated and grown
thank you
so thank you for the question um so so
yes indeed
but it has it has been an evolution in
that sense that the first we set up
those farmer networks
we looked at that multifunctionality
we allowed that to grow and then we
actually said okay we want to go from a
traditional agronomy push
do conservation agriculture use my
better varieties
to kind of a pull but at the same time
that pull then also can leverage some of
the other things that we're looking for
which is that extra income
by creating a market for the grain so
very simple asking the food the beverage
companies to
instead of buying the grain in in from
outside and importing it to buy it from
from local smallholder smallholder
farmers now having that said there's
obviously a reason
that those companies it's easier for
them to buy a ship of homogeneously
produced
corn on on their very intensive
practices as opposed to
small older farmers who who all do their
own practices and so it's less
homogeneous it's it's logistically more
difficult et cetera et cetera so
the big question was also how can we
offset what you lose on the one end with
with gains on the other end so the same
system thinking and that's where it
became important to visualize the other
value of that grain so that that grain
has a value so that you can transform it
in a cookie or you can transform it into
a flake that you can sell
but it also has a nutritious value that
we're not making visible but it also has
a climate a climate
value or or or a a water value and so
with the data systems we're working
together with those companies to
actually say this grain
has not only the value that you can make
it into a to a flick but if you take two
of those grains this one is produced
sustainably and this one is produced
non-sustainably then choose that
sustainable one even if that costs you a
bit more on the element of logistics or
organization or etc uh and because
that's a value that you can bring to
your consumer um
and so those those those collaborations
started with a couple of companies and
and i can i can
inform that they have been growing today
we have a platform where 80
of the companies using
selling products in mexico based on mace
for example
are participating uh so
those the companies participating in the
platform represent 80 percent of all
maze-based products sold in in mexico
and we are working with them uh to
actually open those local markets
develop those markets and
and and bring the discussions on a level
uh playing field so that i also want to
to highlight it is not about bringing
farmers and companies together and then
say okay now now now work it out because
they start from very different starting
points right it's about creating the the
the
the space where they can uh collaborate
as equal partners
i i hope that responds respond to the
question otherwise i mean i can also go
more in detail uh on that in in a
separate conversation
yeah so my question like um because
you're talking about this whole thing in
the context of climate change so how to
scale this up
to
uh you know from like uh you know
individual trials really like small
scale studies and this uh individual
efforts of course you
of like collaboration and networking
thing but i'll just build this up to
like really regional and global scale
and how that evaluation could be done
sure this is a fantastic
uh comment and
actually we're already struggling to
scale it from those experiments to 300
000 farmers not so we were already proud
that we overcame that that scaling
hurdle you're already proud that we
overcame the the the hurdle of getting a
drug drought-resistant maize into the
hands of millions of farmers not just
hundreds uh and and i think your
question is even more ambitious to
really say okay how can we
bring that to an even higher level which
is which is really the global
and this is where it plays right the the
global the global level and this is
i think where last year we have seen a
couple of things where we need to learn
from know that if one if one particular
uh
waterway in the world is blocked by a by
by a ship that went broke the whole
system the whole system uh
collapses so so
talking about scaling it seems to go
very fast uh in a negative way as if you
have the right pressure point i think um
i was jealous that that we now know that
pressure point i would like to know it
the other way around not to say what's
the pressure point that we can activate
to the other way around to actually
spread out in the in the in the system
so we can we can elevate it now having
that said i do think we need to look
more at
very high level
financial systems
looking at the financial system
connected to this looking at the social
systems connected
to this
and and making that connection uh
between high-level decision-making and
and low-level impact i don't have the
response how to do it but let's let's
keep discussing and thinking about it
maybe one comment
visualizing things
making them transparent making them
visible putting the data putting the
light on it already can be a change
can provoke change on on its own
yeah so that's actually the follow-up
question i like to ask the data sharing
part so
you like you have like you said you have
like 30 000 right where
that
number correct uh but
are those data available to researchers
that can help
um submit for the scaling of effort
yeah absolutely so so those data are
available for multiple studies you know
so we have examples of
of students that that looked at that
data based in combination with another
database to look at
the impact of using conservation
agriculture and reduction of burning for
example on on health on the on the
health numbers on blood blood samples
taken to look at a blood contamination
provoked by by by burning just just to
give to give an example so so these are
the kind of collaborations that actually
we would be interested into defining and
saying okay you have this database here
you have the data analytical
capabilities let's make a collaboration
to to look at that uh or and then and
then be able to give recommendations to
policymakers based on that on that
research that is no longer based on the
model but based on 40 000
points in in in the real space uh with
with which we can do something at the
same time we do also have
dissemination systems where where we
send some of the information back to the
farmers
brown i i i made the comment that much
of ag is large scale or quasi-industrial
you know much larger scale than you guys
were
uh historically worked on and my
question is are these solutions you're
working on now are they meant to apply
also you know at that scale as well as a
smaller scale that's
thanks
uh absolutely we were looking at those
solutions under the conviction that each
we need to look at solutions that um
are
i don't want to say skeleton but what i
mean is the solution that we propose
should be the combination
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu